well the nation's largest online
retailer eventually start its own
shipping business we told you yesterday
about a Wall Street Journal report that
says Amazon is laying the groundwork for
its own shipping service sources tell
the journal the Internet giant's goal is
to haul and deliver packages for itself
as well as for other retailers and
consumers that would make Amazon a
competitor with its current partners UPS
and FedEx CBS News contributor Nicholas
Thompson is editor of The New Yorker
magazine's website New Yorker comm Nick
good morning good morning I'm so glad
you're here to talk about this this is
so interesting we've heard rumblings
about this yes because the UPS the
shipping is taking a big cut out of
there cuttin bottom line and they're
absolutely you think it's a reality it
can work well I don't know whether it
can work this is a huge bet for Amazon
we don't know exactly what they're doing
and they deny that they're trying to
take on UPS and FedEx this is a story
that came out in The Wall Street Journal
but it had 30 sources this is this is
happening but Amazon's not telling us a
lot about it so we still have a lot to
learn we don't know how long we'll take
what happened is that a few years ago
Amazon had a lot of problems shipping at
Christmas so they started building at
its own capacity so they could have sort
of flex capacity when they when they
needed it now it seems like they're
actually going to try to make a whole
business and have there be three
companies that you can go from they will
surely still ship some packages through
FedEx and UPS but they all have their
own business and then the big question
is will they ship their competitors
packages now a statement by Amazon says
essentially they're supplementing
amazing yes Amazon always supplements
its competitors right I mean this seems
like they want to be seen as
supplementing right now but as many
people quoted in that story and in
Business Week say supplementation is not
the plan yeah but just look at what they
did in the enterprise zone yeah I mean
they built a huge business simply
because built on the thing that was
already doing for yourself right this is
absolutely a similar power right so what
Amazon did there is they built the whole
cloud computing infrastructure which
last quarter was more profitable than
their retail business which is crazy
they host Netflix they host almost the
entire Internet based on infrastructure
they are building themselves they
studied and they expanded to others so
this may be completely parallel they're
studying how shipping works they're
gonna expand it and possibly provide it
to others or possibly know a friend of
mine told me the other day you can get
anything in Amsterdam azan whether it's
food for your hamster surprise new show
new shoes new clothes so why wouldn't
they do this it seems to be a genius
idea to most people from the outside
again right but shipping his heart
remember DHL was the last big shipping
venture to go out there say yeah we can
do this we'll get the trucks out there
we'll solve this problem where's DHL
right now it's actually pretty hard to
do it right how are you gonna insure the
trucks how are you gonna really have
enough capacity if you don't have enough
orders can you do it efficiently will
you be able to fill the trucks we know
Amazon can pack the boxes right we know
they can study where the truck should
drive but this is a hard business to get
into and FedEx and UPS I think they're
pretty good but they also have time to
practice they're having a lot of time to
practice and there's a lot of
information that they have that their
competitors don't have right Amazon's
big secret the big advantage is that
they have all the data they've been
collecting and study and they know they
have one big customer for sure right is
there anything that seems to be too
risky for him to take on well you know
he was asked this question I was
listening to an interview he did this
summer needed somebody asked a serious
question like what will you not do and
he's like I don't think I'm gonna go
into the oil industry and he's doing a
pretty good job at it so here watching
posting oh yeah they like it yeah
thank you very much Nick always good to
see